yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
killed young from Italy counter dam or a
very strong blitz player I have from
number of videos already against him
it's playing thus laughs and no a 6 g3
is line that I recently am so down
interesting I didn't even know that you
can play Bishop f5 against that hmm
maybe you can G 3m was played by a
chrome leg against am against Luke
McShane last year in the london classics
and tell her he got a very very nice
position with this move yeah the look on
his haven't always makes a funny
impression but how exactly do you um
yeah do you use this weird rock position
I I don't really know this looks a very
solid for black should I play c5 at some
point him I don't really know how else
to to get only heaven taking on d5 is
probably just stupid maybe I can
reposition my pieces here for be for a
for the Queen on b3 doesn't make make
much sense
hmm not quite sure where to put it yeah
you don't really want to put it all the
way back but I don't really see well if
I want to play with before I form where
else should I go on a4ai will probably
play five so okay so completely
different position now the ship if I've
is probably a stupid song 22 yeah as
usually is playing this very actively is
always tried for active play even if
it's not working at him here it is
probably working
yeah deform us a bit unstable okay a
very enterprising play I don't really
think it is good though I mean g4 very
nice but what about the f4 square isn't
there night coming of course um it's not
so easy but still uh-huh here he
probably wants to get give a check here
alright so let's let's keep a four in
mind yeah this is always so ambitious
yeah there's the kind of chess of you if
you don't grab your chance that counter
play you simply get ruled over it's
probably working here I don't don't
really know
yeah okay let's open up him maybe it's
not not really really really working but
cannot stay passive here
her divorce is unfortunately just
hanging how do i get rid of all this
okay maybe maybe something like that I
mean we are we have been fighting your
hand to hand combat on the King side
while he's got a rook on a seven so
maybe maybe this isn't so clear 94 could
be good I didn't look about look at that
94 is probably strong just attacking g3
I didn't do that Joe
just a texty form
yeah him if he wants to tape he plans to
take before now then he needs to take
every first and then this would really
good weekend the light squares
tremendously
it takes on d4 I can even take with the
night Nina's played this very ambitious
Lee but also created some weaknesses on
its own is king porn on age 6 it's
probably not not entirely clear what's
going on here Wow okay
so cheeky checklist
yeah if I've got Queen edge fire firm at
some point but I didn't think it was so
strong at the moment now I can can take
here first aged six was saying why
wasn't I taking okay okay but the ruckus
doesn't have any other I gave away this
was check here why check okay yeah okay
it's not really clear or anything but
what a mess
yeah this position is probably very good
for white but I don't have anything on
the clock I'm just a ticking with with
almost all pieces time learning of this
bloody check here unbelievable tweenage
form
check yeah this is winning for white
green age 7 and queen age 6 check check
black resigns wow what a finish yeah i
mean i was probably completely outplayed
hear this all these aggressive moves I
don't know it looked at looked very very
shaky I thought that 94 was good yeah
Queenie one maybe it's still along okay
but I don't know and now all hell broke
loose computer wants to sacrifice on d5
now okay okay didn't think about that
are here h5 is strong h5 had just traps
look really okay but I needed to to play
good Jenny yeah and this is very good
for what yeah the computer says white is
winning which based on intuition i also
thought in the game because I now have
have many pieces in the attack look at
this year this is excellent this is good
the queen is working and this is just
just not defending a night f6 also was
strong but this wins as well yeah now I
recognize this is capture I of course I
wanted to take here but he can take on
each and this I didn't want to want to
have so
I played that and here probably you can
defend yahoo k6 defense well this just
gives away the game and loses instantly
yeah of course a big blunder here at the
end just just a big fight with a very
messy game alright thanks for watching